first of all let's talk fashion this is
very romantic for you I know it's not
like me but I kind of love it
yeah it's redemption yeah and the shoe
is cute charlie
yeah I have a new dangerous tattoo to go
with it I like two weeks scratch so
listen tonight is ladies night at the
AMAs and it is time to bring it with
your performance so what are you doing
pressures on because nobody Mariah JLo
and Taylor performance I know you don't
see funny is so this year I kind of
everyone's coming with these like
massive productions you know what I mean
and they do them so well the dancers the
costumes the flames the production so I
am taking an alternative approach little
more strip back me and Betty and Khalid
are gonna kind of show you guys how the
record came to life and it's gonna be
really intimate and really special did
it like the this record is everywhere
how did it was one person and then
others joined on or did you all meet
together well Benny and I have worked
together on a couple songs my last album
and you know he was trying the idea
around and putting out of the record of
his own and he asked if I'd be a part of
it and it was really natural again if we
were in the studio and I just kind of
started writing and he had this demo he
did with a cheer in and everything came
together it was amazing yeah so missin
movie star how is the reaction been to
your acting darling I mean I only had
two lines so yeah it was really crazy
because you know a stars born is such a
poignant film for musicians I think to
see so many things and themes in that
movie are so real for us in our lives
and it was funny seeing it in the
audience at the theater you know there
was a lot of people in the room we were
like oh there's palsy at the beginning
of the movie and then after watching it
I think they kind of had a new
perspective on maybe what my life might
be like it might be a little different
than they think it is you know
so Lady Gaga and Bradley just absolutely
killed it it was my favorite movie I've
seen all year so I'm so happy I get to
be a part of it
[Music]